A SMART app must be registered with an EHR's authorization service.
Before it can be run within that EHR and access data from it,
the registration technology is up to the EHR vendor,
although SMART recommends the OAuth 2 dynamic client registration protocol.
No matter how it registers at registration time,
it must register one or more fixed fully specified launch URL's and redirect URL's.
EHR's can offer SMART apps to
the provider in ways that greatly increase their likelihood of use.
In this example from Cerner,
the apps are in the same main menu that the physician uses for other charting activities.
This greatly facilitates the usability of
the apps by saving time through eliminating extra clicks.
Also note, the display of the apps information,
which is patient education in this case,
conveniently happens in the usual clinical data presentation area of the EHR screen.
Alternately, as shown here,
an app can launch standalone.
This is actually a design prototype done by a group of my students
for an app that supports epilepsy patients via their smartphones.
This kind of standalone patient facing app and
apps for providers launching within an EHR session,
are probably the most common use cases for fire.
In an EHR launch, as shown here,
SMART passes and opaque handle to the EHR context to the app as part of the launch_url.
The app later will include this context handle as
a scope parameter when it requests authorization to access resources.
Note again that the complete URL's of all apps approved for use by users of this EHR,
must be registered with EHR's authorization server.
As shown here, when an app is launched standalone from outside an EHR context,
it requests authorization to access a fire resource by redirecting it's
authorization request to the EHR's authorization server.
Based on predefined rules and possibly end user authorization,
the EHR authorization server either grants the request by
returning an authorization code to the app's redirect URL,
or denies the request.
The app then exchanges the authorization code for an access token,
which the app presents to the EHR's resource server to obtain the fire resources.
If a refreshed token comes along with the access token,
the app may use this to request a new access token with
the same scope once the original access token expires.
This has been just a basic discussion of SMART app authorization.
The important details are readily available on the excellent SMART on-fire site.
There are also numerous web tutorials about OAuth 2 and open ID connect.
Google provides an interactive OAuth 2 playground.